I uh um I'm pretty bullish on some kind
of national dissolution peaceful divorce
National divorce Civil War whatever and
you're polished on Civil War yeah like I
don't mean to say that something I want
to do something you want oh you're
saying that you're you're thinking the
likelihood yeah I'm I'm looking at it
like wow that's gonna happen okay and
it's it's crazy that there's been a lot
of things that you know uh Jack Murphy
likes to mention this it was last year
in January we had a conversation about a
lot of things we predicted a bunch of
stuff that was going to happen based on
what we were seeing and I remember Jack
hitting up being like dude you need to
go back and watch the episode we did was
like the first guest we ever had oh yeah
and he was like we predicted a lot I was
like really he's like yeah dude and I
was like wow so I see these things in
media and I I think one of the things
about it
there are a lot of people who tell me
I'm crazy for bringing it up
but now it's starting to change man I
thought it was so funny I'm not afraid
to speak my mind and give my opinions
even if people think they're dumb like
when I was like I didn't like Dune
everyone's like you're insane dune's the
greatest movie I'm like I don't care if
I if I feel the way I'll say it back in
the day when I used to talk about Civil
War people would be like you're nuts
it'll never happen now I have people
being like so you've been talking about
Civil War like I did Russell Brand's
podcast and he's like yeah you said
Civil War and then I go through all the
details shooting in Pacific Northwest
let me show you this story
so you can explain so you can understand
how I feel this is a tweet from Max
Blumenthal he's a leftist and it's from
a show Primo radical it says Noam
Chomsky doubles down on his previous
call for the state to segregate the
unvaccinated from society quote how can
we get food to them well that's actually
their problem let me play this video
when you talk about folks having the
freedom to you know separate if they
don't want to abide by these vaccine
mandates what would that look like on a
practical level does that mean that
folks uh need to just stay home and have
like groceries delivered to them does it
mean like separated communities of folks
who are unvaccinated or just you know
how do you think this would practically
play out
same way as with people who say that I
don't worry I don't want to accept
traffic rules
I suppose different people who said it's
an attack on my Liberty to make me stop
at a red light it's government overreach
we don't want the state to have that
power over my private life well such
people have to be
they should have the decency to remove
themselves from the community
if they refuse to do that then measures
have to be taken to safeguard the
community from them then comes the
Practical question that you ask how can
we get food to them well that's actually
their problem uh of course if they
really become destitute then yes you
have to move in with some measure to
secure their survival just as you do
with people in jail for example
so there you go Mrs Dom Chomsky he is a
prominent figure on the left that's why
they interview him and this had to be
probably the most infuriating thing I've
ever heard but at least Nam Chomsky has
become senile enough to admit what they
want to do it's not about vaccines it's
about mandate you saw him talk about
traffic laws yeah yeah if someone blew a
stop sign are we going to put them in a
camp and then and then deliver food to
that no but think about what he's saying
the same thing that happens if someone
refuses to abide by traffic laws yeah
they get a slap on the wrist they get a
20 ticket yeah and they're told to go
home so when I brought up vaccine
minutes I said I tweeted this
I said the left tries claiming that
vaccine mandates have been around
forever weird I don't recall being
carded for my medical information
entering a bar before but if you say so
and then income the leftist being like
all of these mandates for like smallpox
smallpox mandate Supreme Court ruling
1905. it was the Jacobson ruling I
believe it was called it was over a Five
Dollar Fine the guy didn't want to pay
the equivalent of 150 for not getting
the vaccine they didn't say you weren't
allowed to go to restaurants they didn't
say to stay home they didn't say we're
going to segregate you from society they
didn't say we were going to cut you off
from food they said pay about 150 bucks
and you're done and he said no took him
to court the court said you know what
they can find you over this and that was
it and from that ruling we got I think
it was was the back ruling in the 19
1927 where they ended up sterilizing 70
000 women because they use the
justification of government mandated
medical procedures to sterilize people
the state deemed imbeciles so when you
see Noam Chomsky say segregate these
people from society and if they want
food that's their problem I hope you're
paying attention to what prominent
leftist figures are saying they want to
do to your kids then don't come to me
and say but Tim I can't stand up for my
rights my kids need food congratulations
when you don't gnome chomsky's gonna
come and take it away and it's not just
Chomsky it's not just commentators it's
world leaders like the prime minister of
New Zealand that was asked directly uh
are you creating a two-class society of
people who are vaxxed and unvaxxed with
special privileges for the ones that are
vaxxed she responded resoundingly yep
and and that's what they're literally
doing in implementing as far as policies
here and we have to be made aware of
that so plagues have been a major thing
in human history and there actually is
this like extensive legal tradition of
the state having extraordinary powers in
the time of plague to do all kinds of
things for quarantines and all this
other stuff but that was back again when
you're talking about smallpox
pre-vaccine that like you know people
were like dying in the streets with open
sores and like was incredibly contagious
that was you know killing you know three
quarters of entire towns like the
survivability rate of covid is you know
extremely high and they're treating this
like it's you know again smallpox
pre-vaccine I mean it doesn't it never
has Justified these kinds of draconian
members Ian brought up a really good
point uh recently when he asked us about
the you know where the line is in terms
of vaccine mandates and he and I was
like I don't think what we're seeing
warrants the kind of minutes they're
doing and then Ian was like okay so but
but if it's Ebola then their rights be
damned and I was like that's a good
point you like Airborne bullets aerosol
eyes and people's insides are liquefying
and they're dying and then I was just
like you know I think about it and I'm
still like then you should isolate
yourself from from everyone else if you
don't want to take those risks which
which brings me back to the original
ruling that the left tries to cite and I
want to say I'll say two things one
they said if you don't get the vaccine
it is a five dollar fine just like if
you blow a red light they say it is a
fifty dollar ticket five dollars back
then was about 150 bucks now as I stated
so for Noam Chomsky to say the same
thing that happens the other thing they
bring up is schools MMR vaccines yeah if
I want to go to McDonald's for a
cheeseburger I don't have to present my
cards because of schools yeah still
something completely different but my my
greater point was if they're openly
saying if we have the power we will do
this to you then the only outcome I see
I see this I see two groups of people
pointing the finger saying live by my
rules or else technically it's not true
the right tends to be saying leave me
the F alone and the left says shut your
goddamn mouth we are going to lock you
up if we have to there's also a lot of
pushback against Chomsky uh against his
point of view here one person writes
glad I was able to learn a lot from
reading and watching Chomsky and glad I
was smart enough to learn when it was
time to stop listening to Chomsky
another person just chatted here also
Noam Chomsky is the is the Grinch Who
Stole Liberty and I would have to agree
with that person
my entire life it's it's insane people
have been following gnome Chomsky around
transcribing his every utterance like
literally that's what they do with him
and the only other figure in human
history I can think of where they did
this was Jesus Christ and he is not
Jesus Christ I mean he said so many like
dumb and Ill consider things over there
I think he happens to have said some
interesting things over the years what
he was saying about corporate media in
the 80s was interesting uh but you know
he's he's spouted off on so many topics
over the years that goes so far beyond
his quote-unquote domain of linguistics
or whatever it is that the fact that
we're still listening to him at this
point in time never mind that he's
saying things that are terrifyingly
authoritarian but let's let's think
about what he's saying when he says we
would need to take measures to protect
Society from the people who won't get
vaccinated he is operating under the
assumption that he is society that he
controls it and that it's his it's not
true so here's what I posted when he
said the food actually that's their
problem no no actually that's your
problem Farmers support Trump 85 to 12.
oh boy truckers support Trump ten to one
so if you think you're going to isolate
these people from society and then you
will be trying to be the nice person to
figure out how to feed them you're
sorely mistaken yeah you'll isolate the
people who bring the food to your city
and then they'll give you the finger and
you'll say but wait I'm hungry that's
not sugar-coated he's calling for camps
he's calling for people to be relocated
outside of society outside of their
homes put into special facilities where
they are concentrated
we would ensure their survivability much
like jail Australia is already building
camps for 2020 and 2022 and 2023 they're
still building even more or on top of
that so this is not even in the realm of
conspiracies this is not only just being
talked about by Chomsky this is being
activated in parts of the world right
now where they have camps for people who
don't comply the CDC director just came
out today and said that they she has a
plan for unvaxed government employees
and police and it's to re-educate and to
provide counseling for them she said
specifically quote there's a plan should
these people not want to be vaxxed uh
what's the plan with the exact details
she didn't really get into all is that
the word re-educate unironically I mean
you you you're the bad person you see
that New Zealand prime minister lady
yeah no I saw that when she was when she
was asked by a reporter are you going to
be creating two classes of people yes
that's exactly what we're doing
yes I I think it's cool they're not even
hiding it yeah they're so emboldened by
the mainstream media cheering them up
and blowing smoke up their took uses
family friendly show I would have said
something else let's also not forget
that they're they're Shifting the
definition of what's vax now yeah now
all of a sudden it's going to include
you know you don't have your seventh
booster for the you know um you know
Alma crosstalk the definition for herd
immunity as well this you can only
surely destroy the language University
of Denver flu vaccine mandate
you know I I'm just so astounded that we
as a species can make so many movies
books shorts about apocalyptic Futures
and Nightmare dystopias and right now
we're living in one and people are like
this is fine
seeing that story about Noam Chomsky and
then seeing people high profile blue
check marks agreeing with him you really
you realize who the Nazis would have
been well
there's also something here which is
just that our culture is so empty and
devoid of meaning here now look I'm just
speaking as a Christian you know like I
live for things other than what my
government does on a day-to-day business
or on a day-to-day on on a day-to-day
basis
um but the fact that these people are
the number one thing that they're afraid
of is just dying constantly you know
what I'm not afraid of dying I'm
professionally not afraid of dying for
something I believe in and once upon a
time that was the dominant attitude in
America people had things they were
willing to die for you know that's a
really interesting thing you maybe just
realize something I'm not afraid of
dying I'm afraid of not living so for me
when they say things like you have to
live in a cubicle lockdown you can't go
outside people would rather not live but
be alive I'm the other way around I
would rather risk my life in order to
live right well look they're going to
get to live and and Mark Zuckerberg's
metaverse or whatever it is whatever VR
goggles they bolt to your head and
they're beautiful pod
but people are going to gleefully Enter
the Matrix
you know it's it's some of them are well
but that's the classic Huxley Orwell
distinction right yeah I mean like you
know everything that's all well but you
know the reality is Huxley probably got
it more right than Orwell you know we're
all gonna Sleepwalk into this because it
seems like the fun thing to do I
actually think Luke got it more right
Revenge of the Nerds or the other ones
yeah well I'll share it with all of the
dystopian novels and we're in between
all of them because it is government
overreach but it is the pleasurification
it also is the censorship like
Fahrenheit it also is
V for Vendetta right no that's the
funniest part very accurately
um there's so many things in those
movies that are playing out in true life
it's it's kind of awesome why are we so
good at predicting all of this so
terrible reacting to any of it and why
do people cheer on the people fighting
against the big tyrannical governments
and corporatists but yet on Main on you
know in the real world they're cheering
them on like Julian Assange but then
Trump was like I don't know who Julian
Assange is this is my favorite point to
make about the original Star Wars It's A
New Hope I always ask people like are
you a fan of Star Wars yeah true you
like the A New Hope uh the original one
yeah the original trilogy yeah you think
a story about a bunch of religious
zealots who come from a desert take a
cargo plane and blow up a military base
is a cool story
I mean I guess but I was also raised
Mormon so uh
um
you know so my former colleague Jonathan
last is a guy that wrote the famous
essay about how the you know the the
empire were actually the good guys right
um that you know got a lot of traction
back in the day yeah I mean I totally
see where you're coming from with that
I'd love to do a series of short films
villains as the good guys so we could do
a ton of different movies and do like a
five minute short film where it just
breaks down does a quick you know
overview of the bad guy's actually the
good guy and Darth I tried for so long
just like Luke just like just like that
Karate Kid video on YouTube that
describes Karate Kid but in a totally
different lightning perspective right
right but they made a show about it yeah
and Cobra Kai basically but you know
Darth Vader he's a disabled veteran bro
there you go he's a he's a he's a war
hero of the Clone Wars if you joke about
it enough it just may come true there
was a Galactic Civil War and he lost his
limbs fighting against religious zealots
to save you know what government and
shamples now of course we know the
emperor was secretly fomenting all this
stuff that's besides the point you know
Darth wasn't in on it well Mark asked
the question why we're so good at like
coming up with these stories but we're
so bad at reacting to them and I think
that is because people who create art
have a much deeper understanding of
human nature than the people who make
our policies because looking at the way
Democrats are trying to handle this
pandemic they are assuming that people
are going to go along with them if they
force them to do it like have you ever
met an American that is not a good way
to get an American to do anything look
at these protests in New York you've
seen these these crossing the bridge
chanting let's go Brandon exactly and
the day before that the Kyrie Irving
protest outside of the Barclays Center
where they stormed in to try to get into
the Barkley Center and there was they
pretty much had a lot of people out
there all chanting let Kyrie play you're
like I'm glad the fight in this country
isn't you know dead but having said that
you know I don't know maybe this is you
know my age and you know stature talking
as it were but I I have a feeling that
even 25 years ago so much what we're
seeing would have been a non-starter
yeah and not just because of the
technological stuff that enables this
but simply because the cultural
attitudes were like so much stronger in
terms of and people were stronger
healthier happier and had more families
and now we have a lot less of that but
then all of the mainstream stuff would
have been put on ABC and it would have
been fact we would have thought oh
millions of people have been this and
that and like yeah he's right Vietnam
War I mean there was a huge push they
realized the mistake they they realized
the mistake they made by putting cameras
there so they didn't do it for the first
Iraq war they decided not to show the
doors getting kicked in in the first
Iraq war in the 90s yeah they showed
like a news reporter sitting on a tank
driving through the desert but they
didn't show like kids getting mowed down
in their houses and stuff as the
soldiers were kicking the doors in and
white phosphorus there was an age of
muck raking Journeys that did make a big
impact but it's hard to kind of weigh
these things it's hard to really assess
them by not living through them and and
and only having the reports from what
happened uh of the reports not the
actual events so it's hard to say
exactly what was the Lynch point if it
was the media if not and I think it's
impossible to answer those questions
thanks for checking out this segment
cast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time